can you please go Mr
President
Madam President of the
European Commission ladies
and gentlemen Vice Presidents and
Commissioners dear colleagues we
are very happy to welcome you
today on the occasion of your
trip to  paris which marks
the official opening of the
french presidency of the council of the european union
please accept my apologies for
not being physically at your side i
am by the choir and by the spirit
but as you know  lakovic 19 am
still away from the national assembly for a few hours or a few days,
this being a crucial moment
for us before we receive our
colleagues from the 26 member states in the
many interparliamentary conferences
that we have planned.  arranging
this presidency constitutes for us an
important event that is
exhilarating and above all full of hope the
period is indeed unprecedented
confronted with the challenge  of the pandemic
evolving in an increasingly
unstable world europe has been able to renew its
ways of thinking and break many
tamils ​​to meet the
contemporary challenges it
faces
sciences of its pranks as well as of these
vulnerabilities
the european union is determined  to
adapt its model to the new
ambitions of today in order to better
respond to the aspirations of
European citizens, this
is moreover the meaning of the slogan
power membership revival chosen
by france for its presidency
power because our union must no
longer be afraid  to be sovereign to
protect its borders to
adopt a real defense strategy and
to demand loyalty and
reciprocity in trade relations
our union, which is the first continent
in the world to commit to carbon neutrality
in 2050 can be proud to be
at the global forefront of the
fight against climate change
with the digital legislation we
let's hope for rapid adoption
the european union will have its
own liability framework
applicable to large platforms is in
line with its values ​​it will be a question of
building a regulatory model that
will preserve competition and fight
against online hatred and france
will be firmly committed to promoting a
new growth model
geared towards innovation in favor of the
ecological and digital transition. It
is moreover in this perspective
that our first
interparliamentary conference in Toulouse on
February 7 will focus on the challenges of
digital and  space belonging
then these are of course our values ​​and
this question will be at the heart of the debates
of the cosac that we will welcome here at
the national assembly
but belonging is also solidarity
which is the basis of our model of society
the  france wants to complete the
directive on the minimum wage
in the european union
it will also endeavor to
encourage unity and d  cultural diversity
common history and exchanges
among our youth it will bring to life
the proposals of the conference for
the future of europe and finally the recovery
the recovery plan would have been
unimaginable a few years ago and
yet these appropriations are  already on the
ground, a
symbol of European solidarity
,
the challenge now lies in
the appropriation of all these policies
by European citizens,
whether it concerns ecological or digital transition, this
is the meaning of the major
conference that we will be organizing in  the
loire valley focused on europe at the
service of citizens with debates on
the implementation of the glass pack and
the new common agricultural policy
you will have understood it the abz and gentlemen
you will find here at the
national assembly of parliamentarians determined  to
advance the European union, which is
why we attach
particular importance to your visit and
it is with great pleasure that
I  welcome
I thank you for your attention
thank you very much Mr President
ladies and gentlemen the vice-
presidents ladies and gentlemen the
presidents of committee
ladies and gentlemen the presidents of the
group ares all my college we are very
happy to be here with you today
to celebrate the opening of the
French presidency
and we salute your priorities relaunch
power membership
the years I told you Mr.
President are enormous
first of all the two major themes the
fight against climate change and
the digital transition but is
well but of course also the
current crisis the fight against the pandemic
with good coordination of health
and economic recovery as you
mentioned
and finally a more sovereign europe and
that goes from the protection of the
external borders to the advance on defense
European
also so you see there is a lot to
do a lot to work I count
on the po  ids policy and on
the experience of france one of
the founding members of the european union
in this case and here i would like to briefly
briefly mention three
important areas the first area and of
course the climate
you know that together we have fixed
climate targets for 2030 and
which are really the pride of europe
in the world and we were the
first as continue to have a
law on climate targets
now the commission has proposed a
very ambitious very
detailed roadmap for each  objective for
each sector with a strong
social dimension that is really important for
us and we all know that
climate change does not wait it is
getting worse, that is to say 2030 is
almost tomorrow and our roadmap
must  be in place in time to honor
our commitment and that is why we
are really counting on the
French presidency to advance the green pact
that we European citizens ex  igent
the second theme is you said it
Mr. President digital
I am delighted that digital is a
real priority of the French presidency
excellent we you know our
legislative proposals we have put them
on the table proposals for
services  and for the digital markets
it was important for us that we
find that the two are closely
linked
because taken together
they target both businesses
and citizens and we have great
confidence in our ability in your
ability has completed its work on these
two files
the third theme
we are going to address in the
coming months are social issues and
major economic issues
you mentioned the directive on
minimum wages but also the
directive on transparency in
remuneration
the question of investments
throughout europe
and  there on this point I simply want
to say it is important for
n  ou to see that we have a completely
new economic situation resulting
from the covit crisis we have the
need for investments because of the
green deal and the digital as
we said and all that requires a
thorough examination of European needs it is  to
say, we have to rebuild, reconcile
the need for the budget, the need
for reforms, but also the
need for investments, that's
the taz now for the months to come,
and for all this, we're counting on the
French presidency
when we really  of course, ladies
and gentlemen, we have taken good note
of your work on European affairs
, in particular your
report from last October for a
strategist dress at the service of citizens, thank you
very much for that and I am very
happy that this national assembly
and the senate  has decided, you said so,
Mr. President, to organize
the Cossack together, it's so
important because it will allow us to
continue  re our exchange not only
today but in the coming months
so for us your contributions are
an inspiration an invaluable contribution
for European debates because we
all know that parliamentarians they
are there European citizens
thank you very much
thank you Madam President